It's summer concert season.
You want something to wear that's, like,
light and cute,
keeps you safe,
has pockets. You could carry all your own stuff.
And easy access to pee.
This Halara easy peasy dress is perfect.
I am so excited for the summer concerts.
You can just throw this cute little dress on.
Never gonna get too hot,
keeps you cool,
keeps you cute,
and keeps you conveniently able to go to the bathroom quickly.
And I just love that you can hold your own stuff.
I hate when you have a dress,
you know, sometimes the pockets are bulky out here.
This just solves every problem with any dress ever.
I absolutely love it.
You will, too. It's linked right here in the TikTok Shop.
There's huge discounts for first time users of the TikTok Shop.
And it's free shipping and free returns. Come on!